[music]
>> As far as
As far as it in a Jumu'ah khutbah, for
example. So, we see many of the khatib
who give the Jumu'ah khutbah, they hold
a stick while speaking. So, will that
reduce the impact? And the other second
connecting thing to it it is that if
there's old person and if he wants to
give a speech,
so he may need the help of a stick if
it's a long speech, etc. So, will that
reduce the impact or is it okay? Farik
has asked a question
that
many a time the khatib in Jumu'ah
khutbah hold a stick
and that's a sunnah. Scholars differ how
important the sunnah. There are many
sunnahs. Some are sunnah mu'akkadah,
sunnah ghair mu'akkadah. So, if you
consider it to be a very important
sunnah and you want to hold it, it
overrules everything else.
But,
very few of the
khatib hold the stick while giving
Jummah Khutbah because they consider it
is a Sunnah but not that important. So,
if you belong to that category of
Muslims who believe holding a stick
while giving the Jummah Khutbah is a
very important Sunnah,
it overrules any other techniques.
If it's haram, you cannot do it. So,
it's not a fard to hold the stick.
No scholar says it's a fard, it's a
Sunnah. And that also people differ. As
far as I've been to several mosques,
thousands of mosques in different parts
of the world, a very small percentage of
the Khatib, they hold the stick.
In the Haram also, I doubt whether they
hold the stick. Do they hold the stick
in Haram?
Ibrahim, no.
So, it is a Sunnah,
but people differ.
Now, coming to the question the old man
wants to give a speech, a long speech.
If he cannot stand,
trouble, then he sits and gives a
speech, preferably.
Because if he's holding the stick for
support, that means it is very
difficult. For him, I would advise him
to sit and give a speech.
May Allah let not that time come to us.
May Allah raise us at a time when we are
in the best of Iman and our best deeds
totally there. But now, person difficult
for him to stand, leave aside gestures.
If he feels difficult and he's resting
on it,
then better it is that he
sits and gives a speech and learns the
techniques of sitting and giving a
speech. Even while sitting, you can be
effective. And the best example is Dr.
Israr Ahmed. Dr. Israr Ahmed is one of
the most powerful Urdu speakers.
And he's very powerful.
And the modulation is good. He sits and
he gives a speech.
Hope that answers the question.
Regarding the impact on both the
situations,
at least for the first one, for the
Khatib.
>> Yes.
For the Khatib, it will reduce.
If he's holding a stick, surely it will
reduce. One of his hands is blocked.
He's holding a stick, it will reduce for
sure.
But if he thinks it's a very important
and he wants to do it,
no problem.
But most of the people don't think it is
that important now.
It is there.
It's not a fun. Depends upon the person.
And
for a person who's leaning down, he's
finding trouble. So what natural is
everything would go down. The better he
sits and he speaks, it'll be better.
We'll go to the second category.
That's
the personal appearance.
And in the personal appearance,
the most important according to me,
it is a beard.
Because our beloved prophet Muhammad
said,
it's mentioned in Sahih Bukhari, volume
number seven, in the book of dress,
chapter number 64 and 65, hadith number
5892 and 5893. Ibn Umar, may Allah be
pleased with him, he said that the
prophet said,
"Grow your beard
and trim your mustaches.
Do the opposite of what the
Jews and the pagans do.
Grow your beard and trim your mustache."
Now this is a commandment.
Now if there is a commandment
of the prophet
without any contradicting action,
it becomes a fun.
In the rules of Sharia,
if there's a commandment to do it and
there's action opposite, for example,
the prophet commanded that you sit and
drink. Don't stand and drink. But
there's a sahih hadith
which shows that the prophet even stood
and drank.
So sitting and drinking becomes
mustahab. Standing and drinking becomes
makruh.
But as far as the beard is concerned,
it's a commandment of the prophet
that grow your beard and trim your
mustaches.
And according to all the four imams,
Imam Abu Hanifah, according to Shafi,
Imam Ahmad ibn Hanbal, Imam Malik. All
of them say that keeping a beard is far.
There may be certain scholars from Egypt
or somewhere may say it is
not far.
But
the authentic scholars
there is no two difference of opinions
in this.
All the four Imams also say keeping a
beard is far.
And your beard
may not be good like mine. You know,
it's very sparse beard. Now at least
alhamdulillah when I started when I was
in the medical college you know a little
bit here, a little bit here, a little
bit here. And a Muslim brother says,
"Oh mashallah, Zakir, what noor?" I
said, "Jazakallah for encouraging me. I
know it's not good.
But jazakallah.
I believe if the beard is good, a proper
good beard who has a good beard like
Arshi.
And like brother Ibrahim.
Both the Ibrahim, Ibrahimain. The two
Ibrahim's here. In Arabic you put ain.
Ibrahimain.
Both the Ibrahim's have good beard.
Me.
So if you have a good beard then you
keep
alhamdulillah sawab. If you don't have a
good beard, don't have a good growth and
yet you keep for the sake of Allah and
his Rasul double sawab.
If you're looking handsome and you keep
like brother Arshi looks mashallah.
Arshi.
Ibrahim here.
Ibrahim Qureshi. They look handsome with
a beard. But if you have a beard only
for Allah then you get double sawab.
But if your beard is not good and yet
you keep, you get double
Yes, some of the non-Muslim like beard.
So there's a difference of opinion
whether the beard looks good or not. I
am least bothered about the opinions. I
say even if it looks bad on me
and I think it doesn't look good, I
feel, I may be wrong.
But all the more reason I keep because
purely for Allah, no two doubts.
If it doesn't look good and you're
keeping me no two doubts. If it looks
good means I don't know whether I'm
keeping handsomeness or keeping for
Allah and his Rasul. Correct?
So, when it doesn't look good and then
you're keeping, there is no iota of
doubt that you're doing only and only
for the sake of Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala.
Now, this beard of yours comes in the
factor of
key number one.
Doesn't come in key number three.
Key number one is key number one,
brother Kamaruddin.
Help of Allah. Surah Al Imran, chapter
3, verse 160. If Allah helps you, none
can overcome you. If Allah forsakes you,
who is there that you can help you? So,
let the believers put their trust in
Allah.
So, beard is
a fard.
And alhamdulillah,
most of you have a beard.
Some may be because
of
the area they come from, the beard may
be very sparse. But, few
or very few who don't have a beard, I
expect that you stop
shaving from today.
Or even trimming.
And the same Hadith
of Sahih Bukhari, volume seven, in the
book of dress.
Hadith number 5892, it says that Ibn
Umar, may Allah be pleased with him,
he took one fist and he
cut it.
That means
according
to various Sahih Hadith,
the correct size is one fist.
If it doesn't grow one fist, you cannot
do anything. But, if you want to trim
it, trim it after one fist.
And then no less than 10 Sahih Hadith in
which the Sahabas did trim. Though there
is some opinion of certain scholars that
you should not trim at all, but Sheikh
Nasiruddin Albani, who was one of the
greatest scholars of the last century,
which I spoke yesterday about, he says
it is wajib
fard
to trim after one fist.
This is the opinion, let's not go into
that fish. But, keep a beard preferably
to a die, keep it one fist.
Some believe that you should not cut at
all because the Hadith says, "Grow your
beard."
So, grow means don't cut. But again, you
have to see what the Sahabas did. There
are 10 sahih Hadith including Omar, may
Allah be pleased with him, who trimmed
it after one fist. So, how do you grow?
You grow like the Sahabas grew. How do
Sahabas grow? They trimmed after one
fist. And there is no sahih Hadith I
know of single
which says that the Sahabas never cut
their beard. I don't know any.
In my research, in my limited knowledge,
I don't know of a single Hadith. And the
Hadith that Muhammad Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam's beard
touched on his chest is a da'if Hadith.
The Hadith which says Muhammad
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam's beard
touched on his chest, if it touched on
his chest, that means it has to be long.
Longer than one fist. One fist will not
touch on your chest.
Unless you
bend down too much. So, in my research,
anyway, let's not go to Someone wants to
keep long and if he really believes
that's a requirement, then
alhamdulillah. If you don't really want
to be there, but the Hadith is that a
beard you should keep.
So, inshallah,
I believe
all of you inshallah will keep a beard.
All already have, I know, but to help
those who don't have, could you please
raise your hand and inshallah I'll keep
a beard at least one fist.
I know many have. No, keep means keep
till it grows, don't shave.
Fine. Now, those as I said earlier,
maybe people coming from China.
There are Chinese who have masha Allah
big beard also. But most of them, their
growth is less.
So, as long as you don't
shave and if the growth is not there, no
problem. You cannot say, "Okay, little
is there, let me shave it because the
growth is not there."
So, as long as you don't use a razor
and don't use the scissors, and as much
as it grows, even a millimeter, no
problem. Zero also, no problem. You'll
get the equal reward. If your niyyah is
there.
If your niyyah is there that I would
have never that I would have never kept
it then no so what Allah knows the near.
In sha Allah.
So keeping a beard is very very
important.
>> [music]
[music]